salut fis ça fait quelques temps que je
n'ai pas parlé de livres sur cette
chaîne
alors attention ne fuyait pas parce que
ce livre là c'est juste de la bombe
aujourd'hui on va parler un petit peu du
contenu du livre d'olivier roland le
best-seller qui s'appelle tout le monde
n'a pas eu la chance de rater ses études
et sans trop vous teese est derrière ce
titre un peu aguicheur se cache
réellement un pur contenu olivier
rolland l'auteur je crois que je les
rencontre et au mois de mai on a dû se
rencontrer pour la première fois au mois
de mai de cette année et en déjeunant
ensemble on s'est déjà rendu vite compte
qu'on avait beaucoup de points communs
par exemple les mois on a arrêté les
études classiques assez tôt pour
s'autoformer et l'un comme l'autre est
sûrement vous on a toujours été à la
recherche de hack pour ce optimisée et
sans le connaître à l'époque quand il a
sorti son livre ya quelques années je
m'étais jeté dessus
c'est la première fois que je vois un
livre dans ce domaine qui contient
autant de références scientifiques il ya
plus de 400 sources scientifiques à
l'intérieur ce qui fait forcément que
tous les vaches sont à noter d'ailleurs
mais c'est surtout ce qui fait que le
contenu de ce livre est très intéressant
en fait il a fait un travail de
regroupement de tout ce qu'il a appris
ou de techniques et lui qui l'a qu'il a
créé alors pour améliorer son puits pour
améliorer sa concentration en fait pour
s'améliorer tout court puisque le but de
ce livre c'est que tu puisses cartonné
dans n'importe quel domaine après l'idée
principale cedac et ton éducation pour
apprendre efficacement et du coup en
faisant ce travail de recherche de
filtres en compilant tout ça dedans mais
en le mettant toujours en corrélation
avec des études scientifiques
hé bé ça devient une mine d'or en fait
j'utilise un petit peu le mot bible
parce que je trouve que je trouve que
c'est le cas dans cette vidéo je veux
revenir rapidement sur 5.2 du livre qui
m'avait partie le moins intéressé sur
l'ensemble des points pour devenir ce qu
olivier rolland appelle un rebelle
intelligent promet point la loi de
pareto à l'intérieur il ya tout un
chapitre dédié à la loi de pareto qu'est
la loi du 80 20
en clair vilfredo pareto avait constaté
un jour que 80% des richesses était
détenu par 20% de la population et de la
même manière 20% des pays se partagent
80% des ressources mondiales ce qui est
intéressant là dedans c'est que si on
fait le parallèle sur d'autres choses
par exemple sur les techniques
d'apprentissage
ça peut voir à dire que sur toutes les
méthodes qu'on utilise seulement 20 %
d'entre elles génèrent 80 % du contenu
qu'on apprend et on peut résumer sa part
cette phrase 80% des effets sont
produits par 20 % des causes et je suis
assez d'accord avec ça c'est à dire que
une fois pour le coup qu'on a identifié
quels étaient les 20% de cause on va
pouvoir éliminer ce qui sert à rien
ou ce qui sert trop peu pour optimiser
ses 20% là et soit être encore plus
productif dans ce qu'on essaie de faire
ou dans ce qu'on essaie d'apprendre
qu'ils soient encore mieux général du
temps libre on se détendent ou pour
faire autre chose d'autres projets peu
importe dans le livre on retrouve aussi
énormément de choses entre
l'intelligence brut et l'intelligence
sociale ces terres qui remet pas en
cause le fait d'apprendre c'est bien
d'apprendre et au contraire en fait
d'apprendre toute sa vie mais dans
l'idéal d'apprendre de manière pratique
par exemple sont d'essayer d'apprendre
une nouvelle langue lui applique la loi
du 80 20
c'est d'ailleurs qui va lister quelle
est la population mondiale parlant cette
langue
quelles sont les méthodes
d'apprentissage et de là il va en
extraire quel est le plus rentable et le
plus efficace
et quelle est la langue la plus parlée
pour faire son tableau des 80 et savoir
réellement quelle langue et avec quelles
méthodes
il est rentable d'apprendre
l'intelligence brut c'est le fait
d'avoir des connaissances dans un
domaine comme on apprend au cours des
choses comme ça en bloc sans avoir
toujours de buts derrière l'intelligence
sociale est un petit peu différente
alors elle vient d'une connaissance
technique théorique parfois mehal a
quasiment toujours un but par exemple
moi dans le tournage des vidéos dans
l'écriture d'un montage j'ai appris au
fur et à mesure et au fur et à mesure de
mes besoins j'ai pas cherché à tout
savoir d'un coup j'ai essayé à chaque
fois de faire des petits pas en fonction
de mes besoins et en fait l'intelligence
sociale c'est surtout la capacité
d'analysé et de réagir c'est d'ailleurs
qu'on peut être premier de la classe
barre des 2 mentions sur un diplôme en
particulier et ne pas s'en sortir après
dans le monde de l'entreprise ou de
l'entrepreneuriat s'ils ont choisi cette
voie là le livre il est assez consacré
d'ailleurs simplement parce qu'on n'aura
pas eu les tips pour réfléchir pour
analyser pour s'adapter et aussi pour
communiquer socialement et pour le coup
le système scolaire tue un peu cette
créativité qui est nécessaire en fait à
la réflexion et à l'adaptation pour pour
aujourd'hui pour plus tard et c'est pour
ça qu'en troisième point j'aimerais
revenir sur tous les passages sur l'auto
éducation qui est je pense l'inde est
l'un des trucs qui m'a le plus plu à
l'époque dans ce cas comment apprendre
vite tout le temps efficacement et avec
plaisir est là c'est génial parce que ça
va deux techniques de mémorisation de
comment maîtriser sa courbe d'oubli à
des choses comme ac et votre corps pour
tripler votre énergie c'est hyper malin
d'aborder ce genre de sujet dans le
livre parce que si tu arrives à
optimiser en fait on energy est en
rapport à ton corps ben forcément ton
esprit serait encore plus efficace
sahil
décline en cinq points dans le livre
votre mémoire à long terme votre mémoire
de travail votre capacité de
concentration la volonté et la
motivation qui sont à peu près les
valeurs que je prône sur cette chaîne
depuis maintenant un an et demi avec
toujours ce petit rappel du 80 20
la bonne nouvelle est que pour chacune
de ces compétences fondamentales il
existe des outils et des méthodes 80
pour augmenter grandement vos capacités
commençons par le commencement
la plage est justement en 4e coin jeux
revenir sur quelque chose que je
connaissais pas que j'ai pu expérimenter
cas c'est perturbant mais très efficace
le titre s'appelle comment un objet
banal va renforcer votre volonté votre
productivité
là je me suis dit un objet peut
renforcer notre productivité
je suis pas sûr en fait tout ça vient
d'une étude a encore une fois toutes les
sources et dans le livre c'est l'étude
du miroir ils ont invité un groupe
d'enfants halloween dans une pièce pour
en faire cette recherche là et il y
avait un adulte et plein de bons moments
et l'adulte dis je je pars quelques
secondes surtout ne mangeait pas de
bonbons et il revient quelques minutes
après il ya eu deux groupes différents
un groupe où il y avait un miroir à côté
des bonbons se dire que six ans prenait
il se voyait faire et un groupe où il
n'y avait pas de miroir et bien le
groupe où il n'y avait pas de miroir 34
% des enfants désobéit et manger des
bonbons et le groupe où il y avait un
miroir 9 % seulement ont désobéi et
manger des bonbons
l'expérience a été reproduite dans des
bureaux ou via un miroir sur la zone de
travail à côté de l'ordinateur ou à côté
du livre si des gens doivent réviser et
c est la productivité augmenter jusqu'à
25 30% parce qu'à ce moment là on se
juge soit même si on arrête on se voit
arrêté et c'est très perturbant et on a
tendance à s'y remettre dans les
techniques il aborde pour la volonté il
aborde aussi des points qui étaient pas
qu'ils ne seraient pas moins
spontanément venus à l'esprit comme par
exemple le démon blanc à savoir le sucre
comment gérer sa glycémie quels sont les
effets bénéfiques et négatifs et comment
en fait gérés notre consommation de
sucre pour optimiser sa volonté de ces
hyper intéressant et en dernier point je
vais vous parler de quelque chose que
j'avais découvert dans le livre que vous
m'avez vu faire d'une manière ou d'une
autre plusieurs fois sur la chaîne quand
j'ai écrit mon livre moi aussi ou ce
genre de choses c'est le test des 30
jours en fait ils proposent un test de
30 jours seulement 30 jours pour voir si
quelque chose est bénéfique ou pas pour
vous dans votre vie déjà mentalement
c'est intéressant parce que vous avez
pas vous dire
je veux faire ça toute ma vie donnez une
période donnée de 30 jours pour tester
quelque chose vous vous dites c'est bon
c'est un test ça engage à rien par
exemple vous pouvez vous dire moi durant
30 jours je vais essayer de ne pas
regarder la télé j'ai juste regardé les
replays de quel tel tel est l émission
qui me plaisent particulièrement mais
durant 30 jours je regarde plus la télé
et au bout des 30 jours je fais le bilan
pour voir ce que ça a donné dans ma vie
de positif ou négatif et je déciderai de
continuer ou pas où ça peut agir en 30
jours chaque jour je me débarrasser d'un
objet dont je me sers plus et pourquoi
pas essayer de le vendre plutôt que de
le jeter tout est possible avec la
méthode des 30 joueurs vous voyez c'est
vraiment un point de départ j'ai pas
vous dire en fait tout tout tout ce qui
dit dans le livre mais je pense que vous
percevez la puissance de sa l'agéen
juste d'aborder avec vous cinq points de
la première moitié du livre mais
vraiment je reviens là dessus c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'ultra conclu la
seconde partie du livre est plus axé sur
la liberté et l'entrepreneuriat et le
thème de l'ensemble du livre c'est
comment devenir un rebelle intelligent
comme je vous le disais au début de la
vidéo ça fait à peu près six mois
maintenant que je connais olivier qu'on
se connaît bien mais c'est pas pour ça
que je parle du livre je parle du livre
qu'est-ce qu'il est bien et c'est parce
que lille était bien que j'ai voulu
rencontrer olivier et si vous avez
l'occasion le rencontre un jour il est
très accessible et c'est assez
passionnant de parler avec lui quand
j'ai décidé de faire cette vidéo
forcément je l'ait prévenu je suis
demandé est-ce que tu veux que je
renvoie les gens surtout youtube dont
facebook ce genre de choses si jamais
ils veulent en savoir plus sur toi et il
m'a proposé en fait c'est très sympa de
sa part de vous fournir un extrait du
livre donc dans la description également
sûrement dans une fiche autour de moi ou
je sais pas trop où je vais vous mettre
un lien qui vous permet d'avoir un
extrait du livre ans qu'olivier amis
exprès en place pour nous donc pour vous
et pour ça merci à lui n'hésitez pas à
les voir parce que moins cher que
gratuit je vois pas trop ce que ça
pourrait être donc le voilà allez voir
ça allait checker ça j'espère que ça
vous aura plus avisés bien 4,5 points
j'avais pas parler d'un livre sur la
chaîne et qu'elle livre c'était
vraiment cool de pouvoir aborder celui
ci avec vous si vous avez des titres
donc vous aimeriez que je parle aussi
dites le moi dans les commentaires et
s'il ya des titres qui m'intéresse c'est
que j'ai pas lu je me fera plaisir
également de les lire n'oubliez pas de
laïcs et de la vidéo si elle vous a plu
et vous abonner comme d'habitude tout ça
encore une fois merci à olivier rolland
de nous avoir fourni cet extrait
n'hésitez pas à le télécharger et à très
bientôt ciao
alors si c'est pas encore fait tu peux
aussi s'abonner à la chaîne simplement
en cliquant sur le petit rond que tu
vois voilà juste ici c'est ce petit rond
là ça marche depuis la tablette de
téléphone c'est extrêmement pratique il
n'y a plus de raison d'attendre
allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool
[Musique]